en ce début du mois d'avril c'est en
tant que chef de file d'opposition
qu'elle devrait siéger a battu par moins
de cent voix d'écart lors du premier
tour avec une participation de 38%
philippe brillault est pourtant toujours
maire du chesnay rocancourt une
situation qui se retrouvent dans
plusieurs communes de france le
lendemain du 15 mars
je faisais mes cartons j'étais en train
de vider mon bureau et puis j'avais
envoyé une convocation pour faire le
premier conseil et puis le gouvernement
au dernier moment à annuler le
gouvernement a remis tous les conseils
en place avec toutes nos fonctions ou
autre qu'est ce qui va se passer demain
on ne sait pas c'est pour ça que je dis
que ça on verra après pour l'instant
traitons les gens assureront la sortie
au mois de mai juin je sais pas quand et
puis on aura le temps de parler de tout
ça
chaque jour ici comme ailleurs en france
le maire doit donc gérer les affaires
courantes mais aussi et surtout faire
jouer son pouvoir de police en utilisant
les outils à sa disposition comme la
vidéoprotection ça nous permet avec la
police municipale si jamais il ya des
attroupements anormaux de pouvoir
intervenir des gens disent on voit pas
la police municipale mais on a l'oeil
sur la ville voilà donc ça ça permet à
arnaud à 2 depuis l interface est sûre
le confinement le code général des
collectivités territoriales prévoit en
effet que le premier édile puisse agir
pour prévenir et faire cesser les
maladies épidémiques au contagieuse et
cette gestion de crise pour philippe
brillault est aussi l'occasion de mettre
à profit son autre casquette celle de
médecins en supervisant par exemple cet
atelier de couture au coeur de l'hôtel
de ville où l'on fabrique des masques en
respectant au mieux les normes en
vigueur mais aussi des blues
si on a créé cet atelier ici c'est parce
qu'on est en train de mettre mettre au
point des blues pour notre ehpad pour se
protéger et donc ça permettra de mettre
une blouse comme ça dans chaque chambre
où il ya un isolement de personnes et le
soir on la lave et on emmène neuf car la
ville gère effectivement un
établissement d'hébergement pour
personnes âgées dépendantes celui des
chaînes d'or établissements de 69
chambres
le mairie intervient également en tant
que professionnels de santé donc ce
médecin coordinateur
travail du matin au soir dans
l'établissement et assure pour le
personnel pour les résidents tout ce qui
peut être la sécurité sanitaire et le
suivi je l'accompagnent depuis
maintenant une huitaine de jours
parce qu'il a besoin de souffler un peu
dimanche je les remplacer
et puis on essaye de travailler un petit
peu voilà je suis son son agglo
collaborateurs nous avons actuellement
quatorze résidents qui sont isolées
strictes
nous avons perdu malheureusement quatre
résidents fortes suspicions que vides
pour deux et deux confirmés qu'aux vide
pour ce qui est du personnel nous avons
des renforts
qu'ils viennent essentiellement des
crèches du personnel des crèches de la
municipalité également volontaire
commentaires assurés c'est par eux que
c'est par eux qui sait des volontaires
mais le quotidien d'un maire en période
de crise sanitaire signifie aussi de
s'assurer de la continuité des services
comme celui de l'urbanisme des finances
ou encore de l'état civil
on a les naissances et les décès donc ça
ce papa qui via leur dos qu'il a
téléphoné il aa demandé on lui a ouvert
la porte et il est en train de déclarer
son enfant et pour toutes les questions
des administrés c'est un centre
d'accueil spécifique qui a été mise en
place
il intervient aussi auprès des personnes
isolées référencés dans le cadre du plan
canicule
cette plateforme a l'avantagé d'une
plateforme de convergence pour toutes
les structures de solidarité qui sont
montés dans la ville dans un immeuble
dans un lotissement entre personnes ou
autre ça permet d'avoir ici une
coordination de l'ensemble nous on n'est
pas là pour se substituer à aux autres
on est là pour faire fonctionner tout ce
qui a été mis en place et d'avoir des
échanges d'informations c'est une
structure qui va évoluer dans les
semaines qui viennent parce qu'on est
certain que on va se retrouver à l'est
des problèmes un peu psychologique des
problèmes les violences conjugales qui
peuvent aussi nous prévenir là et on met
en route
effectivement les orientations en
fonction des différentes personnes
habilitées à le faire et pour le
personnel présent volontaire comme
bénévole les principes de précaution
sanitaires sont respectées quant aux
communes et aux maires ils devront sans
doute poursuivre ses actions jusqu'au
début du mois de mai